[Music]
on this saturday night
the review into how rcmp handled colton
bushi's death
the racial reckoning for the family but
will there be any punishment
the outrage over the murders of asian
american women
the high caseload in ontario and the
concerns over reopening
some parts of the province that indoor
unmasked
poorly ventilated exposure is just
asking for trouble
plus the big brains that manage to
outsmart human predators
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us an rcmp watchdog has found mounties
in saskatchewan
acted in a racist manner toward the
family of colton bushi
in 2016 the indigenous man was killed
when he and four friends drove
onto a rural property that night
officers had to inform bushi's mother
about his death
the family claims she was mistreated but
an internal investigation
cleared the officers now three years
later
an independent report is siding with the
family
global's nathaniel dove has our top
story tonight
a civilian watchdog has found rcmp
officers
acted in a racist and discriminatory
manner when telling koldenbushi's mother
about her son's death two reports from
the civilian review and complaints
commission
obtained by global news ahead of their
publication list several inappropriate
actions by officers
and draws a stark contrast between how
police treated the family of gerald
stanley
and bushy in 2016 stanley shot bushy
dead
after the 22 year old indigenous man and
some of his friends
drove onto stanley's property a jury
with no visibly indigenous members
found stanley not guilty of
second-degree murder one of the crcc
documents states
there was no evidence that bushi
participated in any property offenses
it also says rcmp surrounded the home of
debbie baptiste bushi's mother
with weapons drawn they notified her of
her son's death
searched the premises and asked if she
was drinking and smelled her breath
the report found approaching the home
was not in line with a reasonable risk
assessment
that officers were insensitive when
telling baptiste her son was dead
the search was unlawful and officers
acted with discrimination when
questioning baptist sobriety
rcmp commissioner brenda lucky's
response is included in the documents
lucky states she largely agrees with the
findings a university of regina
professor says the reports
highlight a critical failure within the
rcmp
the commissioner does not understand
what systemic racism means
and we have clear examples here of what
systemic racism is in practice
michelle stewart says the reports show
the rcmp
haven't learned from its past in 2020
lucky said she believed there is an
unconscious bias within the mounties
but said she struggled with the
definition of systemic racism
and how it applied to the force steward
says the finding suggests the rcmp needs
transformative change
the first i think it's probably time for
brenda lucky
to maybe step out of this position and
second
there needs to be more accountability in
policing the review concluded by saying
lucky's response missed an opportunity
to take responsibility for the actions
of her officers in this case
the rcmp did not respond to multiple
requests by global news for comment
members of bushi's family say they will
speak on the findings monday
when they are made public nathaniel dove
global news saskatoon
there is growing outrage in canada and
the united states of the murders of six
asian american women in atlanta the case
could be a real test for georgia's new
hate crimes law
yesterday u.s president joe biden
visited the city to help it heal
jennifer johnson reports and a warning
some of the images may be disturbing
across america people are standing up
against asian american hate
after a shooting rampage at three
atlanta area spas left eight dead
including six asian americans building
right now is unification and solidarity
getting bridging communities together
newly surfaced surveillance video shows
confessed gunman robert long
waited in his car for an hour before
walking into young's asian massage
marcus line was there and believes his
masseuse saved his life
when i first heard that first gunshot go
off you know i got back up
you know then the girl got in front of
me she was like wait wait wait
and then once i hit behind the bed i
heard another gunshot i saw her
fall a report by the group stop aapi
hate
finds the u.s on nearly 3 800 incidents
targeting asian americans and pacific
islanders over the last year
some blame former president donald trump
for fueling anger after repeatedly
calling kova 19 the china or kung flu
too many asian americans have been
walking
up and down the streets and worrying
waking up each morning
the past year feeling their safety and
the safety of their loved ones are at
stake
president joe biden and vice president
kamala harris met with asian american
community leaders in atlanta friday
trying to console a grieving city the
asian community
is scared we are living in terror we
have been
for the past year at least the fear is
widespread
after several recent attacks against the
most vulnerable elderly asian americans
this one against a 69-year-old woman
near san francisco was caught on video
while this 75-year-old woman in san
francisco fought back against her
assailant
city police have stepped up patrols when
i see
people's grandparents getting punched in
the face and pushed over
it it breaks my heart asian americans
are looking for help
president biden is urging congress to
pass the coveted 19
hate crimes act which would fast track
federal investigations of hate crimes
while calling on all americans to stand
up to bigotry
jennifer johnson global news washington
to the pandemic now ontario is seeing a
surge in coven 19 cases
just as it loosens restrictions in some
of the hardest hit regions
today the province reported over 1800
new cases
that's the highest since the start of
february despite the spike
patios are back in business in covet 19
hot spots
catherine ward reports unlocking the
patio
is a sure sign of spring restaurant
staff across toronto and some
surrounding areas were busy saturday
preparing to welcome back customers but
only outside i just come to work early
because there's going to be a lot of
extra cleaning and
stocking and we're going to have to
check
you know get the beer draft running all
kinds of things
the regions are still under ontario's
strictest lockdown measures but the
province says it hopes the new rules
will help the economy recover and and
for our regulars to come back and
for them to be on the patio and you know
you know laughing enjoying themselves
i'm i'm looking forward to that for
businesses without
established patios owners say it's hard
to take advantage of the easing
restrictions
still steve achenefdos got permission to
set up a few chairs outside his
restaurant even though he's not
convinced
it will help much because we're
breakfast place so people who they know
we close and we don't have a patio
before
so it's it's very few people they come
in
especially close three o'clock when it
comes to dining out the bigger concern
for some infectious diseases physicians
is how the rules have changed in other
parts of the province where people can
eat inside
with certain limitations one restaurant
west of toronto
in an area with fewer restrictions is
now the site of a coveted 19 outbreak
linked to a variant of concern public
health officials say
five staff members tested positive and
are now in the process of tracking down
roughly 200 customers
but that indoor unmasked poorly
ventilated
exposure is just asking for trouble
experts say this is an example of how
things can get out of control
even with safety measures in place a
restaurant is a unique environment
it is one of the only places we have in
society where people are unmasked for a
significant amount of time
where staff members particularly can be
around a number of unmasked people
catherine ward global news toronto
cases are declining on the east coast
and the atlantic bubble is beginning to
inflate
once again this morning nova scotia
opened its border with new brunswick
people entering nova scotia are no
longer required to self-isolate
but the change doesn't go both ways nova
scotians going to new brunswick
still have to isolate for two weeks on
arrival
the united kingdom has hit a vaccine
milestone
half of all adults in britain have now
received at least one dose
but it's not all good news across the
pond protesters clashed with police
during an
anti-lockdown protest in london
thousands of demonstrators
weren't wearing masks and flouted social
distancing rules more than a dozen
people
were arrested in paris crowds flocked
outdoors today despite new lockdown
rules
people are still allowed to exercise
outside and schools are still
open but non-essential businesses are
shut and there's no
traveling to the countryside france is
in a third wave of the pandemic
on thursday the country reported 38 000
new infections
many are a result of the new variant
first discovered in the uk
hospitals in paris are so overwhelmed
that
patients are being transferred to other
regions
the tokyo 2020 olympics and paralympics
will go ahead in july
but without international spectators
organizers say the risk is too great
refunds are promised for the 600 000
tickets sold to fans overseas
and for the 300 000 tickets sold for the
paralympics
on monday another canadian goes on trial
in china
charged with spying the outcome for
michael kovrick is expected to be the
same as
what came about for michael spavor this
week beijing
isn't keeping quiet about its position
on this case the communist government is
more
than hinting that it was a political
move after the detention of huawei cfo
mong wang zhou in vancouver here's
abigail beeman
he saw us with the lawyer barred from
michael spavor's closed
trial diplomats waited outside and
believe he saw them
so although they couldn't see me because
the windows of the police van were
tinted
i could see them and that was a huge
encouragement kevin garrett lived
through the very same thing
a short closed trial in dandong china my
chinese is okay but my the interpreter
there didn't translate everything
and i i kept asking like can i say
something now
and you know it was no no no and then
yes you can but you can't say that
so it was very confusing he says a
closed trial gave him some hope the
chinese government wanted the issue to
go away quickly
now spavor and the world await a verdict
once the sentence was handed down mr
garrett was returned to canada
so you know there is some precedent for
optimism
in this matter but um you know there's
just too many unknown factors for us to
to really be able to assess it this week
the chinese embassy in ottawa has been
louder than usual
in one blog post the ambassador writes
about difficulties in the canada-china
relationship
saying china takes no responsibility at
all
and in the globe and mail china calls
for win-win cooperation
particularly on trade but claims they
have
never arbitrarily taken a corporate
executive hostage as some countries have
done for a certain purpose
they have said repeatedly that we're a
small country they're a big country and
they're
powerful economy and we're not and so on
and so forth but but the reality is
they do need canada because canada is a
window a gateway if you will to a whole
range of goodwill
economic opportunity political
cooperation and so on
uh from what many people would call the
west experts don't think we'll be
waiting
too long for a verdict in spawar's case
while the second
detained canadian michael kovrick is set
to stand trial
monday robin abigail beeman in ottawa
thanks abigail
coming up a dormant volcano wakes up in
iceland
it was a fiery night in iceland where a
long dormant volcanic system spewed
fountains of lava
for the first time in 900 years it
happened about 30 kilometers southwest
of the country's capital
the icelandic meteorological office
describes it as a fissure
that measures 500 meters the area began
rumbling with increased seismic activity
over a year ago
the last month the tremors increased
dramatically and the area recorded over
forty thousand earthquakes
this is what front lawns look like in
australia's new south wales
the state has been deluged by heavy rain
sparking
dangerous flash floods it forced
multiple evacuation orders
march rainfall records have already been
broken in most places
the downpour is expected to continue for
days
tsunami warnings were briefly triggered
in northeastern japan after a 7.2
magnitude earthquake
struck the region buildings as far away
as tokyo shook
but there are no reports of any major
damage the earthquake
was about 100 kilometers from the
fukushima prefecture
where a devastating 9.0 magnitude quake
in 2011
killed thousands and caused the
country's worst nuclear disaster
details could be coming within days
about an independent probe into
allegations of sexual misconduct
that have plagued canada's military on
this week's edition of the west block
mercedes stevenson speaks with
intergovernmental affairs minister
dominic leblanc about when canadians can
expect some answers
mercedes robin the depth and breadth of
sexual misconduct in the military
continues to rock the canadian armed
forces and has left
many troops asking where to turn and how
the culture of the military can be
changed
the liberal government has continued to
defend defense minister harjit sajin
despite the allegations of misconduct in
the department that he is responsible
for
sajin is one of the biggest fundraisers
for the liberal party and
is a combat veteran himself the trudeau
government has promised an independent
probe into the allegations
but over six weeks later any movement on
that promise has
yet to materialize this week on the west
block i'll ask dominic leblanc one of
justin trudeau's most
influential cabinet ministers and the
person in charge of the privy council
office
when he will be able to tell canadians
and our troops
more about how the investigation will
unfold
we have been obviously very concerned
about these allegations
and the prime minister and the defense
minister have said
that we recognize the need to have a
robust uh
review of these allegations uh that's
expeditious but that's fair
uh and we're committed to doing that and
the minister of defense and the prime
minister will have more to say
in in the coming days the government has
also promised to create a military
sexual misconduct watchdog
but there are few details on what that
would look like experts say for it to be
effective it must be insulated from the
chain of command
and that likely means it would have to
report to parliament and not the
minister of national defense
so far the government won't commit to
that or say
quite what the plan is we have said that
changes
will be forthcoming we have said that
and we have shown across the board as a
government
uh that these allegations and these
circumstances need to be taken
seriously and need to be investigated in
a serious
robust independent way robin the trudeau
government is under
increasing pressure to act to address
the allegations
of widespread sexual misconduct in the
military given their self-described
feminist status as a government
okay thanks mercedes and you can watch
more of the interview tomorrow
right here on global on the west block
still ahead no morning just celebrating
meet the man trying to find the bright
side
of death
death is never easy to talk about and
right now it's especially difficult
because we can't gather with friends and
family for comfort that's why a video
posted online by a scottish man about
confronting what he calls
the final taboo caught donna friesen's
eye
and she's decided to take a closer look
for this week's edition
of the new reality donna
robin tom morton is what's called a
funeral celebrant and he's
written a book about it essentially what
he does is help mourners confront the
loss of loved ones
in a positive way to celebrate their
life rather than
try to avoid the topic of death it's
part of the growing
death positive movement and being death
positive himself
morton recently did something kind of
unusual
this is one way to confront the final
taboo
choose your own grave gravesite tom
morton did it
on his 65th birthday this is the plot
which myself and my wife have chosen to
be buried in
unusual intrepid and an odd birthday
gift to yourself
yet intriguing there is that sense of
taboo that you know you mustn't talk
about death or
if you go to a graveyard it will be
terribly spooky and
it will be horrible and these are not
things we want to talk about but
actually i think it's really healthy to
talk about and anticipate these things
funeral celebrants like morton provide
personalized
non-religious services without all the
trappings
of the funeral industry and that's
important especially during the pandemic
at a time when so many families have
delayed funeral services
there is a danger that we're storing up
grief which could be damaging ultimately
to everyone's mental health
it's not all doom and gloom though
morton says undertakers have the best
jokes so we'll have a little bit of that
famous scottish humor too
robin all right thanks donna you can
watch the full story on the new reality
tonight
on global tv up next
size does matter when it comes to the
survival of this species
cell phone video captured this dramatic
encounter at the san diego zoo
it shows an elephant charging a man who
trips and drops the child in his arms
while trying to escape
the man allegedly carried his
two-year-old daughter into the enclosure
to take
photos the 25-year-old father was
arrested on suspicion of
child endangerment when it comes to
brains the sperm whale
has the biggest on earth six times the
size of a human a new study led by
canadian scientists shows how these
animals
used their big brains to avoid being
hunted centuries ago
as ross lord explains researchers found
a pattern that's raising hope
for another endangered whale new
research sheds light on why the sperm
whale which is an endangered species
was not killed off entirely
in the 18th and 19th centuries whaling
ships like the one depicted in the
classic novel and film moby dick
decimated the whale's population but an
international research team studied
newly digitized whaling log books from
the north pacific ocean
and concluded sperm whales made smart
use of their remarkable asset
the biggest brain on earth we have a
real habit of underestimating what other
animals can do
traditionally sperm whale's only
predator was the orca
staying safe meant forming defensive
circles and smashing their tails
outwards
that tactic left them wide open to be
slaughtered when whalers began hunting
them
the new findings bolster a theory that
the whales adjusted
leaving their formations and swimming
upwind to escape from the whalers
who were also powered by the wind so the
whalers
saw a sperm whale and they went after it
but their success in killing it
went down by about 60 percent in three
to five years
whitehead says the whales can
communicate over great distances using
sonar clicks
with family groups using different
dialects he says is possible they warned
each other in the same way they share
information about where to find food and
they use this information
to at least some of the time and and
more and more often as time went on
behave in a way to evade the whalers
finance could raise hope for the
endangered north atlantic right whale
their numbers are dwindling because of
ship strikes and fishing gear
entanglement
in atlanta canada that does give us a
bit of hope that they can
learn effective methods to avoid
the noise the fishing gear the
plastic whitehead suggests creatures
that survived for millions of years
before humans existed
should not be underestimated ross lord
global news and that is global national
for this saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is petawawa ontario
please keep sending your photos to the
email address you see and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you